Hello guys. For this video
we will tackling about how to promote gender Equality
for each one of us.
Let's talk about it.
First is notice stereotype.
You should not assign or assume gender
when it is unknown.
A great example is gender reveal parties.
You must understand that sex and gender
are two different things.
Sex refers to the physical differences between people
who are male,
female or intersex.
A person typically has to sex assigned at birth
based on psychological characteristic
including their genitalia and chromosomes composition.
Gender on the other hand is a social construct.
As a World Health Organization explains
Chun Water. First,
the social constructive characteristic of women and men
such as norms,
rules, relationship
often between groups of women and men,
a very strong society
society and can be changed.
So instead of gender reveal parties,
which should be sex reveal,
we live in the society
where there's a social system of masculine domination
of the woman.
It's like an attack on the patriarchy.
So the second way to promote gender Equality
is no to subordination.
Our reason for challenging patriarchy lies in
the fact that gender inequality
under pain and intensify stress and vulnerabilities.
This includes notable gender based violence,
but also limited access,
especially by women and girls.
Education, healthcare,
agriculture,
land and water plants
save livelihood opportunities.
That is why we should call off anything
unfair to one's gender.
Men have no right to tell women to shut up.
Man have No right to tell woman to shut up
because men and woman are equal,
period. Lastly,
started at home.
Family lollies serve as the guide
and give as a sense of direction.
This affect the family outlook on life
and their perspective on the world
as well as your identity.
A lot of us have this mindset now
that we must help or influence a large group
of people to have an impact or purpose in something.
However, real change will always start on small things.
It's all started with you.
Remember that.
Be you and own it.
Together, let us promote the society
where all genders are accepted,
not just tolerated.